if transgenderism is real which it's not
but if it's real
then this article that i just read in
time magazine is
totally normal
if transgenderism is not real
and it isn't
it is not real
you're using lots of double negatives
here then this article in time magazine
is the creepiest thing i've ever read
it's called the pain and pride of a
generation changing how it sees gender
the cover photo i'm going to block out
the poor kid's face the cover photo is
freedom a two-spirit 13-year-old posing
for a portrait for time
magazine
time magazine just spent a year
going around the country taking
photographs of sexually confused little
kids this is how they describe it they
say that they're they're taking photos
of gender
expansive
kids
where is chris hansen when you need him
i
i wish time magazine had called my house
said hey do you have any gender
expansive kids living with you yeah no
what's the age limit oh i don't know 13
maybe even younger yeah we want to talk
to them about their sexual desires and
identities
say uh sure come on over at five o'clock
i'd have chris hanson waiting in my
kitchen
hi uh time magazine yeah why don't you
take a seat right over here
oh no i wasn't gonna do nothing no no
why don't you listen time magazine why
don't you take a seat right over here
what were you planning on doing you want
to take pictures of little kids with
sexual confusion it's
super
duper
creepy
we our whole society would have known
this five years ago and exploitative and
wrong in child abuse
now we celebrate it
why we celebrate it because we're
letting the libs run the politics
and the conservatives are just backing
off i bet you i guarantee you the
majority of americans don't think that
we should be taking pictures of sexually
confused little kids
i guarantee you the majority of
americans don't think that 13 year old
boys should be dressing up like girls
and putting stilettos on and stuff i get
i promise you they don't think that so
why are we letting it happen
it's not because the liberals have been
and the progressives and the leftists
and whatever term you want to use have
been so incredibly genius and they're
just they're just unstoppable it's
mostly because the conservatives
surrendered and gave up
even the drag queens get this even there
is a great viral video going around of a
drag queen an actual performing drag
queen saying guys
what why the hell are you all being so
supportive of the drag queens
what in the hell has a drag queen ever
done
to make you have so much respect for
them and admire them so much
other than put on makeup and and jump on
the floor and ride around and do sexual
things on stage
i have absolutely no idea
why
you would want that to influence your
child
would you want a stripper or a porn star
to influence your child
it makes no sense at all
a drag queen performs in a nightclub for
adults there is a lot of filth that goes
on a lot of sexual stuff that goes on
and backstage there's a lot of nudity
sex and drugs okay and honestly you're
not doing the gay community any favors
in fact you're hurting us okay
we have already had a reputation of
being pedophiles and being perverts and
deviants we don't need you to bring your
children around so you keep your kids at
home or take them to disneyland or take
them to chuck e cheese
preach preach drag queen you're telling
it like it is i'd love that line take
them to chuck e cheese what's wrong with
you people what what has a drag queen
ever done
to make you have so much respect for us
you think oh right
it was amazing how quickly the the libs
did this they blurred all the lines
he said gay guys
and we need to tolerate gay guys and by
tolerating gay guys we need to embrace
transgenderism for some reason i don't
really quite know how that necessarily
follows and and then if we embrace
transgenderism we need to support drag
shows there's even a difference between
transgenderism and a drag show
transgenderism is when a confused man
thinks that he's a woman a drag show is
when a deviant man knows that he's not a
woman but thinks it'll be kind of funny
to dress up like one and put on a bawdy
sexual performance those are totally
different things and then this drag
queen he says what
we're basically strippers why are you
why are you taking your kids to the
stripper shows what have we done we
haven't done it all the defining feature
of a drag queen
is putting on
sex shows sexual shows
in nightclubs for adults
the difference between a drag queen and
a stripper well other than the
anatomical differences
is that a stripper puts on a sexual show
and a drag queen puts on a funny sexual
show
a drag show is just
basically a stripper burlesque show with
more jokes and humor
right you have the drag queen and the
drag queens are really outrageous and
that's why when they do the parades up
and down new york they're telling jokes
and doing all sorts of
comedy but it's that's it it's just kind
of a funny funnier sex show
you wouldn't take your kid to a strip
club
why would you take your kid to a and you
wouldn't take your kid even to a late
night raunchy comedy show
why would you take your kid to both of
them at the same time
with a lot of sexual confusion added on
in addition
because we've we it's because
we have lost our minds on indulgence i'm
not surprised that the libs are pushing
this stuff the libs have always had an
interest in sexualizing well everybody
and especially kids they've been writing
about this for a hundred years wilhelm
reich going back to the the early 20th
century this leftist intellectual said
that the problem
all of the problems in the world war
disease everything in between they're
caused by a lack of orgasms not joking
and he said that he had invented an
orgone accumulator to to collect the the
essence of of life and the essence of
the world the organs floating around
this was mocked in the pop culture as an
orgasmatron and lots of intellectuals on
the left had it norman mailer had it j.d
salinger had it bernie sanders wrote
about this kind of stuff and how we need
to sexualize kids he wrote about it in
the 1960s in essays in the vermont
freeman you can still read them
they've been i get why the libs are
pushing this stuff it's part of their
their campaign to upend society in the
words of marx ruthlessly criticize
everything that exists my only issue
here is why i'm being so harsh on the
conservatives here is what have you been
doing they've been telling you what they
want to do for 50 to 100 years now
they've been doing it successfully and
then what do you do you say well you
know it's not my place
if someone wants to put on a drag show
for children that's a blessing of
liberty and that's it's not my place to
ever have a point of view about that
what what
the libs don't think that the
conservatives didn't think that until
five minutes ago i don't i'm not even
sure you really think that
i just think you've just been deluded
or you're so beaten down by the leftist
advances in the culture
that you don't you don't have the
hutzpah to go out and fight come on push
back and fight guys
i'm so glad you like that clip now if
you wouldn't mind ring that bell
subscribe like get the notifications
also please head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
click subscribe and then here's the
crucial part guys
you need to click the link wherever
you're watching this or listening to
this and then you've got to email this
to your friends you have to email it
text it whatsapp at myspace you have to
do it there are still people in america
who do not have the privilege of
watching this show make sure you help to
rectify that today we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]